il a non seulement survécu au pire à
l'excès navalni est aujourd'hui réveillé
et reprend ses sens on ne l'a pas encore
vu mais dans ce communiqué et ses
médecins allemands affirment qu'ils
répondent désormais à leur voie et qu'il
pourra par étapes se défaire de son
aspirateur
le chimiste ville miel zahia 9 à
participer au développement du poison
neuvic turc à l'époque soviétique
il est convaincu qu'une très faible dose
et icare semis sont les vêtements de
navalni avant que son corps réagissent
c'est pour certains médecins s'assurent
vie est un miracle
pour d'autres le diagnostic
d'empoisonnement tout court est purement
politique
interview et aux heures de grande écoute
à moscou le médecin russe qui a examiné
navale née en sibérie maintient qu'il
n'avait trouvé aucune trace de poison
chez le patient le kremlin exigé attend
d'ailleurs des preuves tangibles de
l'allemagne avant de collaborer à
quelques enquêtes qui soient grosse
propagande c'est l'art de la propagande
à son meilleur déplore l'avocate ses
bras droit de navalni new bomb ce boulot
et que tout est votre avis aux tâches
entre 6 à l'excès navalni est un citoyen
russe dit elle qui a été empoisonné en
sol russe
les autorités russes doivent mener une
enquête pour tentative de meurtre coin
l'économie est niée comco jeunes on ne
peut pas encore identifié deux
responsables dit cet autre avocate des
droits de la personne mais tant que le
kremlin refusera de mener une enquête
dit elle il sera considéré complice de
l'empoisonnement navale n'est contenu
que le poison nunchuk est une arme
chimique banny étroitement contrôlés et
c'est essentiellement pourquoi encore
aujourd'hui l'allemagne brandi la menace
de sanctions économiques contre moscou y
compris dit le porte-parole de merkel
la suspension du méga projet de gazoduc
north stream 2 qui une fois complété
devrait doubler les exportations de
pétrole russe vers
europe et ce soir un autre ultimatum la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
donne encore quelques jours au
gouvernement russe pour se raviser
sancoins de concert avec le royaume uni
et l'union européenne
elle promet des sanctions ciblées contre
la russe des menaces jugées absurdes par
le kremlin qui refuse de croire que
l'europe
visiblement tiraillé ira jusque là et si
thammarat altérer ce coup radio-canada
moscou